this was shot in Prague is that we shot
in Prague on location they had an
incredible back lot it was absolutely
freezing I will say I mean when I first
read the script and and having done a
little fantasy movie before I was I was
I hope some of you can appreciate I was
I had a sharp eye on whether or not you
know and I was I was sort of pleasantly
surprised that I really felt like I
hadn't seen this world before and when I
first walked down carnival row I was you
know the Lord of the Rings had an
incredible sets I mean it was one of the
things that drew audiences and people
got to New Zealand to see The Hobbit set
and so on I think people will will want
to go to Prague to see carnival road
because the detail the level of
attention to detail for the set and and
all of the locations you know as an
actor is a dream because you kind of
walk into a space and you're like there
it is here I say you action and we're on
because it's sort of you know it's
filled wholly realized world I mean
there wasn't one part of it which wasn't
real that you could pick up and smell a
real-life pig's head and why is that bad
yeah brilliant
sometimes there's this one there let's
take a look we have a I think we have a
clip here we're gonna take a look at
this scene from carnival row let's check
it out what are you doing head find out
the flooding triggers we both know you
don't give a [ __ ] about that flag you
pretend to tell them I was angry you
know I wouldn't do it
you should we were close any not even
real to you awesome but can you left me
fine oh you left me the rusyn told me
you died do you think that was easy they
were bloody hot
the dice for me you think I haven't
spent the last seven years wishing I had
I was a liability for you I was a
weakness you were and you survived who
would have done more than survive we
have had a reason to
say can I just say like hats off
although I didn't take my house didn't
pick everybody has a softer car in that
scene because we were in I think it was
probably minus 6 minus 10 minus 16 let's
call it that's a 10 flags right anyways
but it was freezing cold rain with
shooting water at YouTube literally
running honor but now they have they
have blimps with shoot rain the blimps
froze so they couldn't use the blimps
with the rain so that's two hoses on us
but all under had a bowler hat on so
when he was shooting when they were
shooting the hose on his ball out I was
just getting the water returned into my
face I was like it was like we had to
stop between